Grab a refreshing tab Cola and a delicious prison burger because we have the 100th episode of American Horror Story.
But before we get into our detailed breakdown. If you haven't checked out Castle Rock, I highly recommend it,
and yes I do breakdowns for it. Hashtag shameless self plug.
We're in 1985, approximately a year after the events of camp redwoods second massacre.
At the beautiful Hollywood premier motel, you know, it's a high-end establishment with the amount of prostitutes in the parking lot.
Last episode, we left off with Ricky and Jingles heading off to Los Angeles to start a beautiful life together, terrorizing this City of Angels.
But a year in things aren't going so well for our friend, Jingles.
We'll get into that in a bit. A German woman on vacation with her husband, Horst and her two
Children of the corn look-a-likes goes over to Ricky's room to tell him to turn it down.
After all they have a busy day at Disneyland tomorrow
Also I love these tiny details, like the husband wearing a Hollywood souvenir shirt
So, you know, they're from out of town.
Ricky opens his smoke-filled room eyeing the German woman, sexually.
In the background, you can hear Billy Idol's Flesh for Fantasy, and we know how much Ricky loves Billy.
He grabs the woman, but Jingles warns him to let her go and what is with that facial hair Jingles?
I mean come on. Jingles and Ricky have been here for a year and living with Ricky has gotten on Jingles nerves.
He doesn't like the music and Ricky lives like an animal. Oh, and they're constantly killing.
In fact Jingles says he's killed 11 and constantly haunted by the faces of his victims.
He wants out but Ricky reminds him.
If you remember at the end of last episode
Jingles was killed by Xavier and later given a second chance at life through the resurrected Ricky.
He made a deal with the devil and although we never hear what this actual deal is
It's safe to assume
It was life in exchange for eternal service to the Dark Lord
Service, which means killing and if Jingles breaks this deal, there will be hell to pay.
Literally.
Paranoid by Black Sabbath
plays as we see a short montage of Jingles watching, disapprovingly, as Ricky kills.
At a nearby convenience store, Ricky goes in for a beer and Jingles changes the song to REO Speedwagon's Can't fight this feeling.
Which has the lyric, "I've forgotten what I started fighting for". Our poor Jingles feels trapped
He's forgotten what he's fighting for. While looking at the paper
He sees that Ricky has been identified and is wanted for murder.
Totally off-topic, but there's also an article talking about hurricane Elena
which was a real hurricane that pummeled, Florida around the same time.
Jingles buys a copy of the paper and gives it to a woman who notices Ricky in the store.
Soon a crowd of locals surround Ricky
calling him el matón, and if the high school Spanish, I mean Google Translate, is right, that means the killer*.
He's chased down by the group and beaten to a pulp, as our tab drinking Jingles drives off into the distance.
And we're back at Camp Redwood in the year, 1989, five years after the events of Episode five.
We meet Dustin, the bird watcher, who stumbled across the camp in search for waterfowl.
He passes one of the cabins, which has since been abandoned and has graffiti exclaiming
"Brooke wants your blood" a nod to how Brooke was framed by Margaret for the 1984 massacre.
Home Sweet Home by Motley Crue plays when we see Montana sunbathing at the dock.
We saw her last episode become one of the ghosts of Redwood unable to leave the grounds,
but it seems as though she's made herself at home wanting to open our precious birdwatcher's fanny pack.
I'm also curious if he takes a photo of her will she be visible in it?
Anyway, she tries to seduce him and he tells her he has a girlfriend. We'll get to her in a bit.
But he succumbs to her charms and is brutally murdered by her
We then see Midge and the other two counselors from the original massacre commenting how unsophisticated
Montana is. Xavier calls them old-timers and proceeds to make out with Montana.
Remember in episode 1, we learned that they used to date
so it looks like they've rekindled things.
The introduction of the original counselours here is interesting
because it may throw a wrench in the idea that; the only people who come back from the dead here are those that need to be redeemed
Margaret Booth is now on Lifestyles of the Rich and Famous
which was a real show in the 80s and 90s, which featured the extravagant lifestyles of wealthy
entertainers, athletes and business moguls.
My god that hair!
She's used her money from her dead husband, the same one we heard about briefly in Episode 1
to buy properties with a dark history and turn them into attractions
Properties like serial killer John Wayne Gacy 's house
The Briarcliff Manor, which was the main focus of season two's Asylum,
Winchester Mystery House
which was the inspiration for the film, Winchester with Helen Mirren and
Spahn's Movie Ranch, where Charles Manson plotted his murders.
And in an absolutely shocking twist, Trevor is still alive and
married to Margaret, the same woman who stabbed him in Episode four and cut off his ear also.
Look at that Sweet cell phone.
This relationship isn't what it's cracked up to be.
Trevor's a coke and alcohol addict and Margaret has given up on God.
Through a flashback, we learned that Trevor is in it for the money.
Rather than accuse Margaret for the murders and lose in court.
He might as well get something out of it and use Margaret as his sugar mama.
But Margaret only agrees if he becomes her husband since you can't make your spouse testify against you.
But now Trevor feels trapped, just like Jingles, when Margaret's assistant Courtney comes in-
this guy just plays the most ridiculous characters.
He was in season three's coven or you might remember him as the eccentric medium Cricket in season six's Roanoke.
He tells them that Brook has just lost her appeal and is set to be executed.
Going down what I believe to be death row, Brooke is confronted by Rickey who has since been captured.
Xavier and Montana go through Dustin's campsite when Ray strolls in pissed that they've killed another innocent person.
None of them know why they're stuck there and the old-timers seemed to be just as pissed as Ray, at the total disregard
Xavier and Montana have for other people's lives.
They uncover a paper telling them of Brook's soon-to-be execution,
when Dustin's girlfriend arrives and Xavier makes quick work over her.
Brooke is haunted by Ricky and the thoughts of her impending death with
The words "Your Final home" written in her cell.
Ricky has somehow astral projected with the powers of Satan and makes Brooke a deal, his master believes
she has potential and asked her to join them to which she politely declines.
We get another shot of Ricky with those black eyes
which we also saw possess Michael Langdon last season.
Margaret receives a report from Courtney that things are going well at their Lizzie Borden property, the woman who was
suspected of killing her father and stepmother with an axe in 1892.
Courtney suggests they sell the business while their business is hot
but Margaret's greed is too much, which is a likely indicator that Margaret will die the season and lose everything.
Trevor shows them a newspaper.-- Damn
There's a lot of newspapers in this episode-- that reports on the two found dead at Camp redwood and since they still own the property
They could be held liable,
but Margaret sees opportunity in this.
We catch up to jingles who has started a new life in Alaska
with a woman named Lorraine, this actress also played Hayden McClaine's sister in season One's Murder House.
Jingles apparently saved this woman's life. She used to be a prostitute,
so it's possible that they met at the Hollywood premiere.
They both now live a happy new life with Jingles working at Video Shack
which is a throwback to video rental stores like Blockbuster.
Here see his new alias Donald and some fun fake movie posters in the back.
Donald might be up for a new position at the opening of a new Video Shack in Juneau, as Brett says
Margaret comes up with the brilliant idea to go back to camp redwood with a food and music
festival. People can actually stay in the cabins where the massacre happened, what could go wrong?
We also see Chet interacting with Montana here, pretty much
confirming that he did indeed die via drowning by Margaret and he wants his revenge.
Jingles watches the announcement of the festival, telling Lorraine
He's over it
He has a new life and he's free
But is he?
Meanwhile back in jail, Ricky is visited by an admirer simply known as Red
She tells him of Camp Redwood's Music Festival and we learn of Ricky's desire to be remembered.
This was hinted at in previous episodes when he admired Jingles for being a legend.
He wants to be one too.
Brooke enjoys her last meal of Snapple and
🤮 I've no idea what that is-
When Ricky offers her one last chance, a last chance she declines.
Ricky has made a pentagram to communicate with his master just like he did in
Episode four and like Michael Langdon did in season eight
he wants his master to give him another shot at immortality and, in return, will give him a torrent of fresh souls
Brooke pleads her innocence, spitting at Margaret behind the glass
She's locked in and given the lethal injection, dying two minutes later
In fact, Margaret and Trevor are bored of the whole process
wishing that they would bring back something more exciting like the guillotine.
At the same time, Ricky has summoned the power of his master
which takes control of the guard who then sets him free.
Donald is chastised by a customer giving them rom-com instead of a horror
Which is probably gonna affect that big promotion he's supposed to get.
When he arrives home, he finds Lorraine brutally murdered.
Luckily his little boy
Bobby is still alive with his sign written in blood saying "Satan will have his vengeance"
The back of it has a picture of the Camp Redwood Festival, leading us to believe it was Ricky who
had the same flyer with him in his cell
I also liked the use of the words gourmet  food and luxury tents
Which were the same words used to describe the disastrous Fyre Festival.
*subscribe to Think Story*
Also think it's a bit weird
If it was Ricky who left that note that he went all the way to Alaska then back to California, that's a really long trip.
Jingles knew he would one day pay for not keeping his deal with the devil and
decides to end everything once and for all, by going back to Camp Redwood to finish Ricky once and for all.
He leaves his child with Lauren's sister,
saying his goodbyes, as if he's never going to come back.
He puts on his iconic,  Mr. Jingles
raincoat and makes sure to bring his keys with him.
And in our final scene, Brooke is resuscitated by none other than Rita.
It's never really explained how Rita was able to bring her back, considering if Brooke was pronounced dead her heart would have stopped
So whatever Rita injected into her veins must have been pretty powerful.
The last time we saw Rita,
she asked Jingles to kill her for what she had unleashed on the camp.
Rita is looking for redemption and from her
conversation with Jingles, knows Brooke is innocent and that Margaret is the real killer.
With Brooke wanting Margaret to pay and Rita in search of redemption,
the two will likely team up and head back to Camp Redwood.
With our characters all making their way back to camp,
It looks like the last few episodes will center around the final Camp Redwood massacre.
I'm just hoping it's not as disastrous as Fyre Festival.
Thanks for watching everyone!
Please make sure to give the video a like and comment below with your theories and thoughts.
You can also reach me on Twitter @ThinkStoryYT.
Until next time remember- daddy loves you very much.